So, we have seen that the duplication of
all the register values that have all, ever been
produced is a problem. So we will located registry
naming, which is another scheme that can provide relief
from false dependencies, but in a way that
actually is more manageable. How does the registry naming
work? So, register renaming separates the concept of architectural
registers, which are the registers that the programmers and
the compilers use. So, this is when you write
an instruction like add r1, r2, r3, the r1,
r2, and r3 that you're referring to are the
architectural registers. In register renaming, there is also. A concept
of physical registers, which is all the places that
we can actually put a value in the processor. So,
there is of course a place for, kind of,
the latest value of R 1, for example, but there
could be additional places where we could potentially store
values that should be going to R 1, and then
what we do is. As the processor reads instructions and
figures out which registers they're using, and remember the program
is referring to architectural registers. As it's fetching instructions, and
decoding them, it also does register renaming which pretty much
means that it re-writes the program to use the physical
registers. So, basically if it sees Add R1, R2, R3.
It is going to rename that into our ad or something else and so on, in order to
basically refer to the places where it has actually
put those values, and how does it know where
the values are? Well, it uses a table called
the register allocation table or. RAT, and you should
remember this because we will be very frequently referring
to the RAT because it's used very very often.
What the RAT is, is a table that says which physical registers has the
value for which architecture register. So, for
each of the architecture registers, there will
be an entry in this table and it will say. What is the current
location in the physical registers, where the
value for that architecture registers can be found?